In Russia Vodka is Water and 12 Other Language
Facts
1) The fear of dinner party conversations
or dinner parties in general is known as Deipnophobia.
2) “School” comes from the Ancient Greek
“skhole”, which meant “leisure or spare
time”.
3) Vodka comes from the Russian word for “water,”
which is “Voda.”
Like most distilled liquors, in the beginning
Vodka was mainly used as a medicine.
Vodka was also used as an ingredient in early
European formulas for gunpowder.
4) A “tittle” is nothing dirty, it’s
simply the name for the dot over the letter
“i”
5) Air Force One is only called that when
the U.S. President is aboard.
It is not a specific plane and the U.S. maintains
a presidential air fleet at Andrews Air Force
Base in Maryland, with each plane meeting
the requirements for transporting the President.
6) The “USA Patriot” in USA PATRIOT Act
actually stands for something: Uniting & Strengthening
America by Providing Appropriate Tools Required
to Intercept & Obstruct Terrorism
7) The term “Speak of the Devil” is the
shortened version of “Speak of the Devil
and he doth appear.
” It was first printed in Giovanni Torriano’s
‘Piazza Universale’in 1666, where he wrote,
“The English say, Talk of the Devil, and
he’s presently at your elbow”.
In 1672, it again appeared in a poem which
stated “Talk of the Devil, and see his horns.”
However, during the 19th century the term
started losing its sinister meaning and was
used as a warning of an eavesdropper to a
conversation rather than the literal Devil.
In the 20th century, it simply started being
a reference to someone who appeared unexpectedly
while being talked about.
8) Glass tubes created by lightning strikes
in sand are called “fulgurites”.
9) The drug Premarin (made of conjugated estrogens)
originally came from the urine of pregnant
horses, hence: PREgnatn MARe urine
10) The only word in the English language
to end with “mt” is “dreamt”, unless
of course you consider “undreamt” to be
a separate word.
11) “Desperation” is an anagram for “A
Rope Ends It”.
12) The Ewoks in Star Wars were named after
the Native American tribe Miwok.
The Miwok’s lived in the Redwood forest
that is the setting for the Endor scenes on
Return of the Jedi.
It has also been suggested that Princess Leia’s
bun hair style was also of Native American
origin, based on the Hopi Indian “Squash
Blossom” hair style that very strongly resembles
Leia’s bun hair style.
George Lucas denies this, stating the strong
similarity is coincidental.
Of course, he also now claims Han shot second,
so…
13) The word “Velcro” is derived from
the French “velour” (velvet) and “crochet”
(hooks).
So essentially, Velcro just means “hooked
velvet”.